>>E BN DI, JAMES "WHITEY"THE 8
COTIOF UL FOF HISDERY I VIRGBUL.
TH THE PRISOS SF
GENETHE THREE ME O
AUS OF HITTINM
PEHE
HARGE OF
REINDA
IN THE FEDERA
SYSTEM.
THIRT WA I
E OF  THIS .
HE WAS OTHFRTHARS THLETHWIE '70s
ARG BI'ST NTS  ANDIF
S.
TH OON INOW SPEANG OUT
SHPUSTATEMNG TM INHE RECAL T
IRIES FA TRAUMTH
TO THEIR AID.Y
>> ALEXANDRA FIELD, THKSS N RED
GE AU OF
SOUTH BOSTON I MER
JOOKHELS
RIE IN THE L ON. YOUR REAC WU DN
LLMER BOSS HAD
EN CHARGED WIT
THANK YOU
COME FROM HISER.SAID THAT HI
D  HAS HNE GOTTICE AS HE'SY OTH.
OF AR.O HOEVERYONE ABOU
DOREO MUCH NEWS ABDEATFORMAN.
ELNG,
PRESCIN I MEAN LONGN
KNOW BULGEO BE IGENERA
PRISON, TH SOMETHING W PIS DEMIS
HE WERE TO BERABLE KNOW, IPOPU .
AN A MATTEFT
HIM BEING SF
BUIN PRISON?>>IRST OF ALL,LED TR
AYE
N  CHARGED
THILTY.
>> SURE.
THIS BECAUSE WT.
WE DON'T K THESE MEN ARE
ES THAT ACTUALLY DID T IT'S INTN
UNTIL PROVEN GUILT
>> BUTSA
FROM WHAEYSA
THAT H HOWS OR
ACTI UUFF  LMOST LIKE TGO INTLAD
TO FACE HIANEAVE THIEARTH, T
INFOAN DALFO
TTH HPOHIMSELF  B
BUT IN THE END HACTUALLY
ANNT
SONK
WANT T AF YOWI.  SO ATAS S DEATA
TODAY? ORGANIZED CRIME ISN'T WHR
ITOT  THINK ANYTHING IS USED TOB
WO MANYSURVEILLAN
STLIKE T
INNOCENCE UNTIL PROV
YOU'VE H ACA R ON
FTMANY